[Music]
we're gonna go to irvine california with
jacob on the line hey jacob how are you
hey i'm doing really well how are you
guys great what's going on
so um
i'm recently married uh we just had the
wedding that we've been planning for a
long time with coven congratulations
everything
thank you um everything went
perfectly well we're very very pleased
but
financially we kind of spilled
everything we had into it
the budget was kind of thrown out the
window uh
probably
three four months closing to the date
but everything went fine we have debt
that we need to address
and we're renting in irvine california
and ultimately in a year or two we want
to try and purchase a home we'd be
first-time home buyers
so
um we've kind of got a big
chore ahead of us
um
so i wanted to ask once we really jump
on all the debt get that out get all
that out of the way
um what what what's your guys advice for
a first-time homebuyer in california
particularly now because the climate is
just
it just does not seem
stable yeah just inflation everything
that's been going on in the news
and value property values out here are
just so high yeah
um
and we're we're kind of anchored by
family so i've already tried to make the
argument uh we should probably leave the
state uh buy a home somewhere else
because it'd be easier for us to do
but um
we're kind of anchored here by family on
both sides so we're not going anywhere
anytime soon gotcha okay um how much
debt do you have jacob to combined
so we're at like 35 000.
okay that's both that's everything
credit card student loans everything
yeah i
uh i can't really take credit anymore
but i mean now that we're married i took
on her debt willingly i love my wife but
uh she she went away to school for a
little bit changed her mind um so we've
got like about 25 000 student loans from
her and then the rest is like credit
cards
and what jaws household income combined
uh we're
very very fortunate we're doing really
well we're about 100 to 110 000. okay
great that is not as bad as i thought
jacob when you said you just had a
wedding where you threw the budget out
the window i like i got he was really
getting over selling this i was like oh
no this is this is bad and it's not that
bad jacob it's not that bad
that's what we're telling ourselves but
we don't want to be complacent
that's good no i'm glad i like that
you're asking and like that you see it
that way that you're that you're focused
on getting out of debt and i like that
you're i like that you're taking that
approach so george walk them through the
baby steps so we can carry the order of
this what is driving this one to two
year timeline to get a house
so it's just the fact that if we're
gonna save ten percent for a home out
here it's going to be 50 grand or more
coupled with the 35 000 that we need to
take care of so we need to save 85 000
in what time frame and based on kind of
how we're living
uh and renting and we hate renting
because we're literally burning our
money i'm getting nothing for it uh
that's just kind of what it looks like
well you're gonna have to actually save
more than that jacob
yeah so what i'm hearing is there's a
little bit of this impatience of like
well there's inflation and california is
expensive and you know we're married now
we have a good income so we should be
able to get a house right
that's what i thought well
uh here's the thing i think renting
right now you're not burning money
you're buying patients uh you guys are a
newlywed couple there's nothing driving
you to have to get a house
and right now we've got to clean up this
debt and as you know you said hey we
need to pay off this debt which
hopefully you're going to do first right
yes that's the plan and then there's a
piece missing here where you need to
have a fully funded emergency fund how
much money do you guys have in cash in
savings right now
uh around
2 000 we're paying rent at the end of
this month like we literally just landed
two weeks ago from the wedding uh paying
off vendors finalizing all that kind of
stuff and we really just burned we
burned
everything like any kind of personal
savings we had merged with our wedding
savings account so wow a lot of burning
going on
okay yeah that's how we were left with
you're basically just starting on baby
step two now which is cool so this is
the debt snowball and so you only have
two debts is it a credit card and
the 25k on the student loans
yes both our cars are paid off um we pay
rent but other than that yeah credit
cards and then student loans okay so we
are going to attack this credit card
with a vengeance we're going to make
minimum payments on everything except
for that smallest balance we're going to
list them in order from smallest to
largest ignoring the interest rate i
know it sounds crazy and we're going to
attack it and with your income if you
guys get focused you can get rid of this
debt within within a year easily does
that sound right yeah your timeline yeah
absolutely i'm thinking six months i
love it hopefully and then with that
other year and a half you're hoping to
save up you know 50 grand for a 10 down
on a on a half million dollar condo i
assume in your area
uh at least some kind of townhome uh the
area if we're gonna be realistic and
we're gonna buy something that
you know is
a relatively new property um
in the area where we're at it's probably
gonna be in excess of 600 650
650 okay and that's kind of and that's
kind of on the low end so realistically
if we wanted
a down payment and she's told me because
she's been looking too and we have
friends that are realtors and first-time
homebuyers they get you know they get
benefits and oh boy
we'll only have to put down three point
five but yeah i'm more real oh no we're
gonna change we're gonna change those
numbers you called the wrong guy man
you asked me for what the parameters are
for a newlywed couple first-time home
buyers don't fall for these programs man
there's all kinds of built-in traps in
here and one of the biggest traps is
putting as little down as you can that's
not what we want to do here we want you
guys to be financially free so here's
what i want you to do
15-year fixed-rate mortgage with a down
payment of 10 percent minimum ideally 20
to help you avoid private mortgage
insurance which is just protecting the
lender not you so that's an extra few
hundred dollars that you're throwing
away if you don't like throwing away
money now just wait till you have pmi
and you're a homeowner you're going to
be spending money all kinds of places so
10 to 20 down 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage and at that point uh you want
to make sure the payment is no more than
a quarter of your take-home pay
so start doing the math running the
numbers we've got a great mortgage
calculator at ramseysolutions.com and
here's what that means it might mean you
know what
two years from now we can only afford a
place that's 400 grand and a year after
that we can afford a place that's 500
grand and so you might say hey we need
to wait because we really want this
place that's 650 and that's more of a
four year time horizon and then you've
got to be okay renting and realizing
that's buying you patience and it's
setting you up for financial success
down the road and the thing that i want
to point out jacob is when we give you
advice that is what we teach here from
ramsey solutions on how to buy a home
the right way we have absolutely no skin
in the game on whether or not you do it
it does not benefit us if you buy a
three hundred thousand dollar home or a
three million dollar home it doesn't
benefit us anyway whether or not you get
into payments up to your eyeballs that
you can't afford or your house poor and
you can't even eat anything or you don't
and so i just want you to know that our
advice to you is for your benefit we're
not getting any commission off of any
programs that we're pitching you and so
the reason that this is so important is
because i want you to learn from how
this feels coming home from the wedding
which i'm sure it was a fantastic
wedding it was also
one day that you spent a bunch of money
on it sounds like more money than you
wanted to and so what uh george is
walking through here are the baby steps
that is the best way to buy a home first
a thousand dollar savings you guys have
that you have an excess of it so take
that other thousand put on your debt
second list all your debts smallest to
largest regardless of the interest rate
attack that small debt begin to pay
those off as quick as possible just like
we said then you're gonna save three to
six months of expenses for any emergency
that might occur because i guarantee you
being a homeowner is full of emergencies
you didn't plan on like air conditioning
goes out or whatever
and then above and beyond that you're
going to save your 10 to 20 percent for
a down payment so we're looking at a
longer time line than you expect and
probably a smaller
house budget that than you expect but
you called asking for advice and this is
it and if you do this
you are going to look up and be in such
a better position financially you're
going to be able to afford the payments
you're not going to be throwing away
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
interest and you're going to have a
15-year mortgage that you're probably
going to pay off earlier than that and
so that's the reason that we teach what
we teach but i want you to stay on the
line you're newlywed let's give you a
year to ramsay plus
take the class in there called financial
peace university watch the video lessons
with your spouse that will give you even
more in-depth advice on how to follow
the baby steps and how to buy your first
home when you're ready